two more
disabled people don't look for sympathy
disabled people people who are ill don't
look for pity they're not saying pity me
they're saying encourage me like
motivate me when they're saying
challenge me I want to be challenged
[Music]
if I can take you from out of your
reality
where we are as humans go through
sadness bad days difficulties but I can
take you out of your reality and bring
you into a world where just me you Vibes
laughs energy love
I can make you do things that you never
thought was possible there you go there
you go NASA Josh man is a fantastic
young man he's a cerebral palsy but he's
had a hard time he lost his mum
he loves his more man and he lost his
mom so he's going through it at the
point halfway through the drill I
thought no he's he's not got it I bet he
talks so deep and I was so proud of him
because I knew that he was he does it
for his mom just said here you go son
good boy good boy yeah somebody who's
already
going through it somebody who's had
cancer somebody who's had excuse a
stroke survivor somebody who's got
dementia cerebral palsy wheelchairs you
almost battles they've got coffee every
single day
so my job is to know what yeah say it
again let me put my let me put that
smile back on your face
like that